good day everybody welcome back to css3
in 30 days today's day number 25 and
we're gonna be coding up some sliding
css3 panels let me show you what that
looks like here we go down in our final
result I basically just have an image
and when you hover over that image BAM
an element slides in to frame with some
text so this one's sliding from the top
when you slap on you hover back out it
slides back out of the frame sliding
from the right sliding from the bottom
and sliding from the left so maybe
already you have some ideas of how you
might want to use this the fact is in
css3 it's incredibly easy to code this
up typically you'd use a plug-in or
you'd write some JavaScript or jQuery to
achieve this effect but in css3 like I
said it's incredibly easy it's slim and
lightweight and I want to show you how
to do that right and now so up here in
the sandbox you'll see what we're gonna
be working with is an image with some
text above that and we're gonna hide
that text into an element we're gonna
slide that in from the top bottom left
and right over here and our code editor
go ahead and download 25 sliding panels
and get it queued up and your favorite
code editor and here in our index.html
let me just show you the mark-up so your
familiar here in the sandbox we have a
section with a level 4 heading that says
slide from top that doesn't really
matter that's just telling you what each
section will include it's this element
that matters to you right here the David
the class of slide and then slide top
right bottom and left respectively
within that day we have a div with the
class of slide content and some text and
then an image with the source of a
placeholder image that I pulled from
place IMG comm and that's a free
placeholder website you can use that for
your own placeholders I'm using that in
this project and again you can put any
image you want in there it doesn't
really matter it doesn't have to be an
image it can be content so let's get
started over here in our sandbox let's
start right from the top we're gonna say
a class of slide we're going to go
position:relative display:inline-block
and overflow:hidden that's because we
want that element on
inside of a slide to be out of view when
it's not within that frame and now we're
going to say slide and then image we're
gonna say display:inline-block this
one's gonna be vertical-align:middle and
that's going to align that image within
the middle of the element if you're
uncertain about how a style works
whether in this video or any of the
videos or just in your projects take it
out reverse-engineer the the work that
you create so if you don't know what
this specific property does then remove
it and see how it effects the output and
then add it back in modify the values
and see an experiment that's how I
learned as a web developer as I started
building more more projects so and
that's how I encourage you to also learn
how to understand CSS properties and
values ok vertical-align:middle
now we're gonna jump in and maybe let's
just see what that looks like if it does
anything so over here in our final
result in the sandbox rather you're
going to see that it doesn't actually do
anything so far because we're not
telling it to do anything specific we're
not actually modifying it too much so
let's move on to the class of slide -
content and we're going to say
position:absolute because we're going to
move that content the content is that
pink box that's are going to slide in
and out we're going to say top
zero left:0 right:0 and bottom zero so
it's stress so they're all anchored so
each side is anchored to every
respective side if that makes sense
wit for 100% height 100% we just want to
make this expand to the full size of its
parent element slide and now what we
want to do is give it a Zen index of one
so it's just in front of everything
we're going to use flexbox here display
flex align items this is a flex box
property flex box base properties we're
going to align the items center justify
the content center and then text align
Center just covering our bases here
let's see this looks like so far
look at this so this is what it starting
to look like it's dead center if I were
to remove the last few properties here
maybe even if I took out display flex as
well so let me take all of this out so
there we go you can't really see any
change when I take out flex but watch if
I took flex out and try to line item
Center it's not going to do that it's
not going to vertically align that but
if I go display flex those that aligned
items is now going to work nice I like
it typically in the past you'd have to
make it display table and then have
another element within there that says
display:table-cell and then
vertical-align:middle but this is way
more lean using flexbox and it's better
it's better to use flexbox rather than
trying to go back to old-school CSS
table technology all right
especially because tables are used for
data whereas flex box is specifically
for visual modification all right now
let's keep going and I'm gonna say
padding I want Pat whoops I want to stay
in slide content I want to give it a
background color action I want to see I
want to see that background pink color
so 225 comma 35 69 and 0.9 a little bit
too see-through and then we're going to
give it a padding of 20 pixels so that
it doesn't over so it doesn't go out
into the edge of the parent
the text color to be white and I want to
give it a box size box sizing a border
box because that padding I don't want to
have it be 100% wide plus 20 pixels I
just want it to be 100% and the padding
within it I right transition transform
0.3 seconds and then ease so that's
going to transition the transform
property that we that we did we add
transform property yet no but we will
upon hover so save that let's check it
out so now we've got that style it looks
good but now what I want to do is hide
it and then have it slide in and when I
hover so let's make that happen
so now I'm gonna say slide hover and
then I want to say slide - content so
now what I'm going to do is say
transform translate and the translate
value allows us to
position where we want to see this
animation so 0 & 0 now what that means
is upon hover I want it to go to 0 and 0
that's x and y but here let's say
directions now what I want to do is say
slide - top and then slide - content so
I'm specifically styling the slide top
element here and I'm gonna say transform
translate so this is by default this is
not on hover I'm specifically targeting
each each element now I want to say
translate 0 and negative 100%
save that that's gonna move it up 100%
of its size its height so now there we
go slide from top you don't see the
element you just see the image of the
cat hover slides down just like that why
do we use translate because the
animation is much more smooth that goes
by points of pixels rather like
fractions of pixels rather than one
pixel to pixel three pixel and it's a
lot smoother of an animation especially
when you have like a Retina screen and
you have really high a really nice video
card and all that sort of stuff using
translate is better for animations
versus using position for animation so
maybe we can have a look at that let me
make this animation go really really
slow ten seconds let's see what that
does
so very very smooth I don't even see any
clunks at all now if I were to use let's
say instead of transforms let's hide
this and let's just use something like
top negative 100% and then if I go top
actually this would be negative 100% and
this one will be zero and take
transition let's go all
so I can already see chunks you might
not see it in the recording I've got a
Retina screen and it's really large
monitor so I can actually see I can see
the the clunkiness if you made this go
slower like really really slow something
like 100 seconds we're not going to wait
that long and then checked it out you're
literally going to see it go down and
you can actually see that
see how it's going down it's just that's
what the animation is actually doing if
they're using top or the position that
position property so we're actually
going to change this to let's go back to
translate and see if that actually makes
a difference and I'm going to uncomment
these remove this oh this is actually
transform okay now let's check it out
amazing difference proof is in the
pudding right here so you can now see
how that is literally sliding down like
liquid even if it's if it's a slow
animation maybe you're animating a scene
of elements like a background scene of
clouds and a mountain and Mario running
across the screen or something you would
use transform and translate because
that's going to slowly smooth it's gonna
be a smooth animation whereas when you
use the top or bottom or left or right
and use pixel values or percentage value
values that's gonna be a clunky
animation this is just sliding down just
super smooth so that is proof right
there why you'd want to use transform
translate for or any other proper
translate 3d translate why and all these
sorts of things these values for
animations because it's very clear the
difference in the animation so let's put
that back which is your 0.3 seconds save
that BAM
it's just nice really like in this okay
so now all we got to do is just gonna
copy this paste it a few more times
change the value from slide top to slide
right and then slide bottom and then
slide left and then you guessed it all
we're doing is changing these values so
slide top is fine we want to change
slide right to x value negative 100% and
the Y value would be zero and then if
you want it to slide bottom we're gonna
do and let's see here we're gonna go
zero and 100% and I'm was wrong here so
slide right is actually 100% that way to
the right and then bottom is 100% down
slide left will be negative
let me see negative 100% on the X and
then zero on the Y save that let's see
if all of these work now I got slide
from right beautiful slide from bottom
perfect slide from left awesome now what
if you wanted to slide from the top left
top right bottom left or the bottom
right you'd simply let's just use one of
these for example we're going to use
just this one I'm gonna say 100% and
negative 100% let's see what that does
that's the slide left see how that's
coming from the top left that's what is
happening there you just have to change
these translate values the X&Y I'm just
going to switch that back and there we
go slide left bottom right and top there
we go there are sliding content panels
with css3 these are incredibly useful
you can use them for displaying your
services portfolio pieces let's say
you're showing a picture of your
portfolio and when you hover over it
content panel slides in displays the
title and a button to click here maybe
you're displaying a product and you're
selling something this the price comes
in with the call to action to purchase
whatever it is that you want to do using
these slide and content panels they're
incredibly versatile I highly recommend
you use these in your own projects and
as you can see the CSS is way way way
easy you don't need any plugins or any
JavaScript or jQuery plain vanilla
straight-up css3 so thanks for joining
me today in day number 25 see you
tomorrow we're closing in on the home
stretch here day 26 coming up see ya
[Music]